dramatic surveillance video shows how
strong wind sent a car tumbling down the
road in Salisbury Maryland it happened
as a suspected tornado through through
tore through the city yesterday no
injuries were reported the storm damaged
homes and businesses a team from the
National Weather Service will be in the
area today to confirm a tornado
touchdown chip Reid is in Salisbury
where a big cleanup is underway chip
good morning
well good morning we'll just take a look
at that damage later today crews with
the National Weather Service will be
here to try to confirm that a tornado
did that something swept through
Salisbury Monday afternoon and it was
not a summer breeze the wind picked up
we felt the glass shattering on the
building the awnings were like almost
ready to live part of this building
crumbled under the strength of the storm
I heard what sounded like a freight
train above the store and it sounded
like bulls are running across the roof
the power of this suspected tornado was
captured by the surveillance camera of a
local pub hoppers tap house lifting the
sedan into the air and on top of another
vehicle a different camera caught
another car rolling down the street like
tumbleweed the car that moved that
flipped onto the other cars actually
somebody was in that general manager
Blake Ben who arrived at the restaurant
shortly after this all went down says
his employees helped pull someone out of
the flipped car and this other gentleman
was breaking the window trying to find
something to get into when they get the
one guy out the National Weather Service
issued a severe thunderstorm warning at
1:37 p.m. for Salisbury which detailed
the possibility of a tornado but an
official tornado warning was never
issued National Weather Service
officials say they believe the suspected
twister touched at 1:40 p.m. three
minutes after the thunderstorm warning
the same system that hit Salisbury
yesterday injured 30 people in Tulsa
Oklahoma Sunday an ef-2 tornado caused
widespread damage without warning the
National Weather Service only issued a
tornado warning after the storm had
passed the city's sirens were never
activated no one died
we were running behind the storm it
evolved very quickly and moved quickly
the city who actually worked well
communicated well it was just on our end
we were behind the storm if what came
through here does turn out to have been
a tornado it will be the second tornado
to touch down in this region in two
weeks by the way the general manager of
hoppers tap house says this building is
a total loss but the main restaurant
just around the corner he hopes to have
that back in business later today
Vlad chip Reid thank you very much